mujeres jóvenes fueron acosadas mediante
manoseos besos abrazos no deseados y
comentarios inapropiados por el
gobernador de nueva york andrew cuomo
así lo anunció la fiscal general del
estado destacando que el demócrata
violento sexualmente al menos 11
trabajadores estatales durante los años
2013 y 2020 de
la investigación independiente concluyó
que el gobernador andrew cuomo acosó
sexualmente a varias mujeres y al
hacerlo violó la ley federal y estatal
específico específicamente la
investigación encontró que el gobernador
andrew cuomo acosó sexualmente a
empleados actuales y anteriores del
estado de nueva york christine quinn la
fiscal también determinó que cuomo y su
equipo trabajaron para tomar represalias
contra una de sus acusadas por exponer
su caso durante la investigación
dirigida por dos abogados externos se
entrevistó a 179 personas
revisando 74 mil materiales entre
documentos correos mensajes y fotos
deshacer un peso pesado del partido
demócrata al presidente yo by the end
reiteró este martes que como debería
dimitir lo que dije en marzo fue que si
la investigación del fiscal general
concluía que las acusaciones eran
correctas recomendaría que andrew como
renunciar a eso es lo que estoy haciendo
hoy no he leído el informe no conozco
los detalles del mismo todo lo que sé es
el resultado final
sin embargo desde que estalló el
escándalo hace cinco meses como de 63
años siempre ha negado las acusaciones
este martes volvió a mostrarse
desafiante for
you know what for me primero quiero que
sepan directamente de mí que nunca toque
a nadie de manera y la propia hoy se
insinuaciones sexuales inapropiadas la
normativa del estado de nueva york dice
que el acoso sexual incluye conductas no
deseadas de naturaleza sexual que crean
un ambiente de trabajo ofensivo 2019
como fue defensor de una ley estatal
histórica que facilitó a las víctimas de
acoso sexual probar su caso en los
tribunales